Speaker 1: Let's go from something horrifying
to something really great.
We need some good news.
My friends, ladies and gentlemen, we got him
after much toil and struggle.
Just kidding.
I sit in front of a camera in an air conditioned
room, but after many years and many videos,
that's more accurate.
The David Pakman Show YouTube channel has
reached one billion views.
That's billion with a B, yes, a b.
Now, I do have a little secret to tell you.
This is kind of anticlimactic, but I might
as well mention it because it's interesting.
On YouTube, the public number of views is
based on videos that are still published and
public.
OK, because we've had a few big videos get
taken down over time because of copyright
claims, because we use unlisted videos for
our member only videos, we actually hit a
billion views in.
Internally several weeks ago, but in terms
of the publicly viewable videos that are still
online today, it happened late last night
or early this morning.
Last night I tweeted guys were like one hundred
and forty thousand views away.
And by this morning we had gotten there one
billion YouTube views.
This is a really big accomplishment.
It puts us in the top tiny, tiny slice of
all YouTube channels.
Some people are saying that that first billion
is the toughest, but we are now view billionaires
on YouTube.
One other note just thinks it's the YouTube
channel has just been killing lately.
I know many people write to me.
They say, David, your show is circling the
drain.
They've been saying that for a decade.
It's actually bigger than ever.
Another really exciting milestone.
We got our first single video with ten million
views recently.
Our top videos right now, again, with ten
million views from 2011.
Man stands on seven hour flight because of
obese passenger.
Second most viewed video from twenty thirteen,
six and a half million views called This is
what happens when you wear a Nazi uniform
in court.
That that was a hell of a story from twenty
thirteen six point three million views girl
makes racist comment to footballer.
He calls her out from 2011 five point five
million views anonymous hacks.
Westboro Baptist Church.
A real tentpole moment in David Pakman show
history.
Then from 2012, just a hair under five million
views.
A soldier attacking a protester at a funeral
from twenty twenty four point seven million
views.
Trump humiliated in worst interview in history.
That's that epic viral AI Jonathan Suan Axios
video.
And then from twenty seventeen four point
seven million views, racist woman harasses
Muslim shopper in Trader Joe's.
I remember there's something avocado related
in that video.
I think it's that the racist woman in the
video has a shopping cart and is in line to
pay, but only has a bag of avocados.
That is really unusual grocery store behavior.
If I'm buying one item, I don't get a cart,
especially if it's a relatively light item,
like a bag of avocados.
OK, now, interestingly, due to the nature
of the content, three of our top seven videos
of all time are completely demonetization.
I'm not complaining, just telling you how
crazy the situation is.
All right.
So thank you for a billion views.
Subscribe.
Let's get to one point five million subscribers
and on to the next billion views.
And remember that you can also subscribe to
our second channel with unique live stream
and behind the scenes content at YouTube dotcom
slash Pakman life.
So it's the two channels.
YouTube dotcom slash The David Pakman Show
billion views, almost one point four million
subscribers, and then separately, YouTube,
dotcom Pakman live.
Exciting new things going on there.